avec douglas y ait ce professeur de
droit et spécialiste de sciences
politiques américaines du glacier ce
bonjour merci d'être avec nous ce matin
sur rtl france peut-être votre réaction
lorsque vous avez vu ces images qui ont
fait le tour du monde de l'intrusion de
deux programmes dans le capitole à
monopinion ces honteuses
mais pas dangereux qui n'augmenteront à
montrer ses forces influentes et c'est
une petite amie des fous et fort trente
mille jambes qu'ils ont vandalisé des
immeubles gouvernementaux et c'est tout
et les forces d'ordre sont arrivés ils
ont chassé comme les lapins
donc c'est le 18ème romain échoué et
cette intrusion qui est quand même
qualifié d'historique a été vivement
critiquée au niveau international
également par les représentants
politiques et d'anciens présidents
américains ce matin c'est une intrusion
qui fera date
ah oui certainement s'il n'ya pas
précédentes depuis 1812 le palais de
congrès n'était pas attaqué et cette
fois c'était les britanniques
donc oui comme tout présidence de dans
l'autre c'est exceptionnel mais ce qui
est très intéressante c'est comment au
fin de compte les institutions très
fragilisé par cette tremblement de terre
dans l'eau trempe on rester debout
le sénat a voté ce matin pour rejeté les
objections
donc c'est fini partie est finie le
débat dure deux heures on regarde les
dernières soutiennent de 30 le plus
propre et plus sain tentes et même ce
débat ne se sait pas c'est que parce que
un seul sénateur
nouvelles fraîches mais non on s'appelle
a soutenu et sinon le procédure continue
et dubaï de ne pas être officiellement
inauguré dans quelques jours les
derniers 1 2 semaines dans notre offre
ne sont pas finis il pourrait toujours
tirer un lapin de son chapeau de
magicien
mais la force de révolution n'était pas
au rendez-vous mais parce que
effectivement vous le soulignez la
démocratie a continué de fonctionner
puisque les démocrates ont appris lors
de victoires dans la sénatoriale en
géorgie encore un événement majeur oui
le passage de pouvoir des saynètes est
importante mais attention ce n'est ils
n'ont pas une majorité il ya qu à 15,9
démocrate et on en dépendantes le
fameuse bernie sanders qui a dans son
rôle d' opposante socialiste pourrait
causer des ennuis m'annonça vote est
essentiel pour toute la dissociation est
donc en bas voir dans les prochains
quatre années en euros d'obstruction
jouer peut-être pro bernie sanders
mais pour qu à malaga ce elle qui va
donner le vote décisif dans les cénacles
s'étonnant vitrine pour ses ambitions
présidentielles
merci à vous douglas ix et x pour votre
analyse ce matin en direct de la
matinale des requérants suite aux
événements et à la situation aux états
unis